thanks to brilliant for helping support
this episode
hey crazies we all know that things are
smaller when they're farther away right
the size of familiar objects gives us a
way to tell distance
except it doesn't always work I mean
you're still good if the distance is
less than like nine and a half billion
light years but there are plenty of
galaxies more distant than that and they
look bigger than the closer ones
[Music]
this demonstration is an example of
angular diameter it's the idea that if
something is farther away it'll look
smaller in our field of view imagine
there's a sphere around your head there
are 360 Degrees all the way around in
any direction regardless of the sphere
size if you see a ball at some distance
it'll take up a fraction of those 360
Degrees meaning you can measure its
diameter as an angle hence angular
diameter if the ball is closer the angle
will be larger if the ball is farther
away the angle will be smaller that's
why one of these clones looks farther
away than the other his angular diameter
is smaller of course our brains aren't
precisely measuring these angles and
doing calculations instinctively you
only need a vague idea of distance
so your brain Cheats by using visual
cues from the environment like
perspective if I replace this background
with one that has less depth your brain
gets confused it looks like I have a
mini clone we call this forced
perspective they took advantage of this
trick and Lord of the Rings to make the
hobbits look smaller we run into a
similar problem in astronomy
environmental cues don't exist in outer
space we only have the vast emptiness
between objects
so it turns out that angular diameter is
not a great judge of distance in
astronomy but when we measure distance
in other ways the pattern still holds up
a kind of
say we've cataloged a bunch of identical
galaxies at various distances
from what we just learned about angular
diameter we'd expect the pattern to look
like this an object's apparent size
should be proportional to 1 over its
distance what we actually see is this
they match up at first but quickly begin
to deviate the strangest part of the
pattern occurs here at about 9.6 Giga
light years that's where the angular
diameter takes a U-turn galaxies start
appearing larger again
what what what I know I know it sounds
unbelievable but it's true we call it
angular diameter turnaround and I'll
admit it's weird AF I've heard it
described as watching Galaxy sink into a
pool of diluted blood and given the
redshift that makes complete sense are
they actually being diluted though well
no I I just thought it would be a nice
metaphor anyways angular diameter
turnaround is just an optical illusion
and like any optical illusion it comes
down to the behavior of light the first
thing we need to know is that light has
a finite speed it's about 300 000
kilometers per second or 186 000 miles
per second give or take that might seem
instantaneous on human scales it's even
pretty fast when you consider the entire
Earth but one step out and scale and we
start to see the problem another step
and it looks as if it's standing still
light takes time to get places and space
is big really big
units can be misleading kilometers and
miles are terrible units in outer space
it would be more helpful to say that
light travels at one light year per year
Alpha Centauri is the closest star
system to the Sun and it's a little over
four light years away that means light
takes over four years to travel that
distance four years and that's the
closest one we can certainly draw the
angular diameter triangle on this image
and Alpha Centauri is close enough that
the simple rule applies but in general
it's becoming clear that time is going
to be a major factor let's incorporate
that factor now before things get too
heavy if you haven't guessed it already
I'm going to use a space-time diagram
why is time on the vertical axis I mean
we had to pick a direction why not
vertical I mean as Michael Stevens would
say it's a it's a choice
it's a choice that choice was made a
long time ago it's just Tradition now
tradition
anyway the Alpha Centauri system won't
move much in four years at least
relative to Earth so in a space-time
diagram they'll be on Parallel paths
your first instinct might be to think
Starlight moves like this but remember
light travels at a finite speed one
light year per year so we don't get to
see this star as it is now we only get
to see it as it was four years ago
there's a delay light has to travel
along diagonal paths in a space-time
diagram we call them null paths for
mathy reasons I'm not prepared to get
into today Just Go With It the long
sides of that triangle defining angular
diameter are null paths for some
perspective that same triangle looks
like this in a space-time diagram I I
know I snuck an extra dimension in there
on you but I promise there's a payoff at
the end of all this
light from either side of Alpha Centauri
A travels along 45 degree diagonals to
reach Earth but if we consider all the
45 degree diagonals we get something
special a light comb specifically
Earth's past light cone every event that
could possibly have affected the
present-day Earth is inside it all light
that could possibly have arrived at
Earth travels along its Edge but this
video is not about nearby Stars it's
about distant galaxies which means we
need to extend this light cone much
further into the past in fact we'll be
extending this cone so far into the past
that it won't even look like a cone
anymore at least not like anything a
rational person would call a cone anyway
this brings us to the second thing we
need to know
space is getting bigger as time passes
it's spanding that means light isn't the
only thing moving here in the time it
takes that light to arrive at Earth from
a distant Galaxy that Galaxy and ours
will have moved farther apart we're not
seeing that distant Galaxy we're seeing
an image of that Galaxy from when space
was smaller in other words an image of
that Galaxy from when it was closer for
a nearby star the space-time paths look
like this parallel for distant galaxies
it looks more like this the paths
diverge in an expanding Universe the
distances between most galaxies get
larger over time but we don't see them
as they are now we see them as they used
to be light from those galaxies has to
travel along the edges of our past light
cone that's those null paths I was
talking about
the farther the Galaxy the further into
the past we see
so the reason they look closer is
because they were closer yep but it's
it's more interesting than that if we
could extend the past light cone
indefinitely like this we wouldn't
actually get the pattern we see our
angular diameter graph would look like
this instead it would deviate from the
simple one over distance rule but
galaxies would still continue to get
smaller there wouldn't be an angular
diameter turnaround like in a real
universe
something else is going on here which
brings us to the third and final thing
we need to know light is also affected
by the expansion of space yes really and
I'm not just talking about redshift
though that does happen light is dragged
along just like the galaxies are light
just happens to be so fast that it's
better at overcoming that expansion than
galaxies our past light cone isn't
actually a cone the null paths gradually
curve toward the Big Bang Singularity
would you call the shape a cone I
wouldn't but then again I'm not sure
what else to call it either it's giving
me serious Taj Mahal Vibes though anyway
the turnaround point is right here
light coming from Beyond that hump spent
some time moving away from us at first
the distance was increasing faster than
the light could move what what what this
is the detail that makes angular
diameter turn around possible even
before the turnaround Point galaxies
begin appearing larger than they should
but they still continue to get smaller
the farther they are it's not until 9.6
Giga light years that we see them start
to get larger again why this happens is
perfectly clear from the space-time
diagram all light currently arriving at
Earth is coming from a point along the
edge of the shape if it's coming from a
Galaxy then it's coming from when that
Galaxy crossed those null paths beyond
the hump looking at further galaxies
means looking at closer images of
galaxies
all we ever get to see are images of the
distant past filled with illusions of
cosmic proportion
[Music]
all right
now I'll admit I did gloss over how we
measure distance as in outer space if
you want to learn more you should check
out brilliant working with a problem
yourself is the best way to learn skills
in math science and computer science
brilliant is a tool for learning stem
interactively they have thousands of
lessons with new content added monthly
learning a little bit every day can have
a huge impact if you like this video I
bet you'll like their astrophysics
course brilliant has several lessons on
how to measure the vast distances
between the stars but maybe you're
looking for something a little more
advanced they also have a course on
special relativity where you can learn
the basics of space-time diagrams
brilliant is college level content for
everyone
if you want to get started with a free
trial go to brilliant.org science Asylum
or click the link in the description
below the first 200 of you will get 20
off Brilliance annual premium
subscription it'll also let brilliant
know you heard about them from me which
helps out the channel
so do you know any mind-blowing facts
about cosmology please share them in the
comments Thanks for liking and sharing
this video a special Thanks goes out to
all my patreon patrons and YouTube
members for their generous support don't
forget to subscribe if you'd like to
keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
since a bunch of you were asking the
Star Trek transporter does allow for
cloning in extreme circumstances but a
real-life transporter would not Quantum
information must be conserved that
information is either in the old you
caught up in the entanglement or in the
new you but never more than one place
anyway thanks for watching